anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow salamander Sally on the Sally
channel of the salamander and you could
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine where if we get more followers
we can get product placement for things
such as bikinis bikinis are great Sally
I once saw her wear a bikini it actually
wasn't as pretty as I thought it would
be I saw you in a bikini you didn't know
I was watching you in a bikini but I was
there this is before I got a girlfriend
it's weird and I could smell her from
far away she smelled like a fart and I
don't smell like farts I smell like
flowers and rainbows okay but Sally that
was amazing that has got to be like the
best video you've ever done see it look
high five hmm well I should get going
since you know you have to edit and then
export and then you have the type of
videos and then upload them and then put
them on all of your social media sites
and it doesn't your subscribers okay
oh my gosh Ryan are you okay
yeah well no I really wanted to hang out
with you why because Sally it's all
about filming in YouTube now what
happened to the days where you know it
would be just you and I hanging out
watching movies eating ice cream I'm
allergic to looking at porn while you
get uncomfortable well I mean now you're
in a serious relationship with Veronica
and I just feel like we can't have that
emotional connection anymore like we
used to because I mean all the things
you used to talk about anyway we're
about my boo and now that's just awkward
I do miss your boob salamander doing
this you're still awkward well Sally I
think it's time I be a sincere and
genuine friend to you
is it that you wanted to talk to me
about running your presence is enough I
don't need to hear you speak sometimes I
don't even want to hear you speak but
being around you yeah that makes me feel
better
you are a wonderful human being
don't say my real [ __ ] name I'm sorry
I'm so [ __ ] sorry we were having
about meeting you almost ruined it
I'm sorry I'm so [ __ ] sorry I'm I'm
so [ __ ] sorry
I like blacks and Mexicans I'm not
sexist love the way women's vaginas feel
and I don't believe in slapping woman
unless they're being a classy [ __ ] it's
Ryan
I know Sally I know but I only say that
about you because I could say that about
anyone on the show why do you say it
about me because Sally you're the
ultimate [ __ ] you're the [ __ ]
I completely understand Ryan and I'm so
sorry for ever bringing it up well no it
was a miscommunication we're just
friends
can you imagine if couples could solve
their problems this easily I know how it
should be so [ __ ] simple to just be
honest and not get defensive about
things and just to try to understand how
each other truly feels I love you Sally
woman ah Monica I don't want to go they
love you I'm so [ __ ] sorry I didn't
mean to say your real name it's okay
Sally I can just bleep it out and post
what do you say we film one more video
you know what Sally I would really like
that
high-five oh we should get promised
rings that we'll be best friends forever
oh my gosh we should I lost my bridge
into a marriage one after I had sex but
this one I'll never lose all right Sally
we're probably gonna be watching a viral
video that is about grossing people the
[ __ ] out hey guys I'm Ryan right hey
guys I'm salamander Sally this is Sally
the [ __ ]